foreign
thinking you could show me anything that
hasn't happened previously oh you meant
previously on the Mandalorian then say
so also one minute and 20 seconds of
pre-episode shenanigans combine that
with the three minutes of post show
Shenanigans and that makes 260 seconds
of stuff in this episode that wasn't
actually episode that means over 14 of
the listed run time is stuff I didn't
need 14 that should be illegal holding
your Amanda Olympics on the recently
renamed giant ass crocodzilla Beach also
are those guys on the left just shooting
at the water what kind of training is
that is that how Stormtroopers train
easy now this is just sparring and
you're using flamethrowers what would
happen if the other guy didn't use his
at the same time your buddy would be
dead this is most certainly not the way
did you transfer in from Cobra Kai
before the reboot
stop teasing a show we all thought grogu
was Force training with these rocks and
then it turned out to only be
Crustaceans if I said it once I've said
it a million times be careful when
thinking about getting your rocks off
because sometimes you end up with
surprise crabs put down the Rocks kid
interrupting grogu's lunch break he is
too small I'm his Ward proceed does din
being his ward make grogu any bigger
what the hell does that non-sequitur of
a response have to do with anything the
training darts and we just so happen to
have one that won't fall off grogu's
tiny little wrist because that's
absolutely something we would use our
limited resources for this is the way
each has three darts you may fire the
darts in any order what does that mean
like you can fire the third one first if
you want to who cares they're all right
there on the same wrist and do exactly
the same thing and considering you find
out in a bit that you fire by squeezing
your fist how would you select one Dart
over another anyway
why would this [__] kid stop at one
guard instead of just firing all three I
mean other than the fact that every
single match in the history of film has
to pretend like we think our hero might
lose don't look at me look at him
signing your kid up for paintball
without explicit consent ready
okay
didn't you just say one round so why do
these feel like multiple rounds and why
does the kid continue to only shoot once
and what even constitutes a catch does
he have to make a common movement after
securing the ball and what about the
grout sorry I I blacked out there for a
second my point is this match is
[__]
did you teach him that not me imagine
what other neat things Luke could have
taught him if grogu had stayed longer I
mean sure if he'd stayed too long then
kylo would have murdered him but surely
he could have learned more than jumping
before getting slaughtered
not having any Scouts looking out for
Danger on what will soon be renamed
giant ass crocodzilla and hungry ass
Velociraptor bat Beach I'm out of fuel
you've done it now that's the Star Wars
has another fuel related plot alarm we
had to install it after the Last Jedi in
Solo it's an automatic 10 cents sorry my
hands are tied no literally Jeremy tied
my hands and stuck me in this recording
booth until I finished saying my lines
gets away this is happy happened before
how incompetent are you as a community
that you have children stolen from you
by a creature and your only response is
to once again see if the fuel will hold
out this time okay fine take your sin
off while I'm distracted by my multiple
orgasms it would kill the child if
they're still alive you mean why is
everyone acting like the kid that got
claw you Inked hours ago by Mr fly
mctify beak would even still be in one
piece you are too young to join them so
please stay back here with me on what
has proven to be a very safe location
just as we shaped the Mandalorian Steel
we shape ourselves Mandalorian steel you
mean best car why not just say best car
we all begin as raw or giving the birds
and the bees talk but using a very
inaccurate euphemism for seminal fluid
that might confuse grogu actually now
that I think about it that's what should
have actually been called grogu
oh look another flashback to order 66.
it's only been shown in episode three
Clone Wars Rebels bad batch previous
Mandalorian episodes and Jedi Fallen
order I'll get one more look at the Jedi
Slaughter just in case we missed
something do you want to order 66 to
become the Batman Pearls of the Star
Wars Universe do you having a series of
flashing lights above the elevator door
that convey no information other than
the set designer thought this would look
pretty everything's gonna be all right
kid ah sudden I'm at best damn it I'm
not made of stone take another sin off
for an awesome Cameo but if you think
we're gonna remove one more sin after
this yusu stepped in big doo-doo this
time don't worry we're gonna meet up
with some friends of mine and I'm
telling you this now without any other
details so the fans will speculate and
we might get a social media bump from it
Stormtrooper aim apparently extends to
Flying ships that can't even hit a
Target that is sitting still on the
ground
Mandalorian steel shall keep you safe as
you grow stronger but won't it also tip
him over that thing has to weigh almost
as much as he does he will grow into
this rondelle as you grow into your
station foundling are you sure about
that Yoda and yaddle didn't seem much
bigger than grogu he might not grow as
much as you expect any closer and it
will hear the ship from here notes exact
hearing range are you an expert on all
winged life tell me bocatan what is the
average airspeed velocity of a laden
swallow stealing a shot for your
fellowship of seven from the much better
Fellowship of nine how do you eat when
other people are around how are you just
now asking this this is the first time
you've been hungry when people were
nearby can we pretend the kid they're
saving is related to Han so I can make a
free solo joke now too late wait until
we clear the area
he's my son which means you throw
caution for your kids life to the wind
I'd love to give him the best
opportunity to survive but you know
Dad's Gotta Dance
somebody rated the old costumes from the
dinosaur sitcom how long have those been
in storage since 1994.
I'm certainly amazed that the kid is
still alive after being inside another
animal but I'm even more perplexed by
the fact that he's bone dry Mandalorian
armor is the absolute best until the
show needs to set up a forged
conversation about the mythosaur later
and then it just falls off mid-flight so
much for the whole don't attack it or it
immediately kills the child thing they
were chatting about earlier I guess that
was only for when they wanted to ensure
a boring ass rock climbing sequence
excuse me waiter uh there appears to be
some Jurassic world in my Mandalorian
I don't think he needed to be told his
dad just got back from the war of course
he's going to see him their whole
YouTube channel is dedicated to this
kind of [__] and we have brought you
three more found Lanes in need of care
and training is that so
hahaha
what are you serious what are you
training them to be Raptor lorians or
riding them like you're from house Manda
Targaryen all I want for my birthday is
a scene showing the moment one of these
idiots was like hey why don't we bring
those three giant baby human eaters back
with us in the ship and then the others
were like heck yeah Frank what a baller
idea certainly we've got everything we
need with us to make this happen and it
makes so much sense in every way long
live the genius mind of the francolorean
I can replace what's missing but not
with its modern refinements what modern
refinements was a regular shoulder pad
it's not like I had a mini dark saber
built into it careful with the Sparks
their armorer there's not enough time
left to accidentally trigger another
expositional flashback but it was real
she's not discounting what you saw bokeh
tan but you're not exactly providing any
proof either this would be like someone
telling me they saw Nessie cool story
bro but until you provide some footage
that isn't a blurry photograph of murky
water the best you're gonna get from me
is a vague congratulations a vacant
smiling nod and a quick look for anyone
else in the room I can go talk to
thank you
boxer versus Raptor
Boulder feels conflicted about fighting
a young blind girl
[Music]
there the nest and here I thought we
were smart just using a hollow map let's
gather around the campfire and sing our
campfire song a piece that I've always
worried about the most is the Crux the
hardest part